eu finance ministers meeting in brussels
will prepare the greek presidency's
monday to finalize negotiations with the
european parliament on the proposal for
a single resolution mechanism to rescue
failing banks this is one of the key
elements of the banking union which aims
to enable in-depth restructuring of
banks undergoing serious financial
problems the greek presidency will
pursue its efforts to iron out
differences with the european parliament
in order to reach a final agreement
before the end of the current
parliamentary term the council will also
be called on to adopt a proposal to
strengthen rules on taxing savings
income derived from interest payments
the new rules will require paying agents
to report interest income received by
taxpayers resident in other eu member
states member states must automatically
exchange information that will enable
interest payments made in one country to
residents of another to be taxed in
accordance with the laws of the state of
tax residents the new directive includes
all types of savings income and products
and requires the collaboration of tax
authorities in establishing the identity
of beneficial owners ministers will also
have an exchange of views on the
economic elements of the eu 2030 energy
and climate framework